vous n'avez jamais eu recours à des
cabinets conseils quand vous étiez
ministre aucun jamais en tout cas
mckinsey non et je n'ai pas commandés
d'études de ce genre là que lorsque j'ai
été lorsque j'ai été ministre c'est
vraiment une dérive nouvelle pour vous
non c'est une dérive qui a commencé son
les précédents gouvernements elle a pris
avec emmanuel macron une autre ampleur
elle a atteint un paroxysme
parce que c'est devenu en fait c'est
devenu un réflexe une habitude dans tous
les domaines sur tous les sujets de
faire appel dans des conditions qui sont
invraisemblables un cabinet pardon mais
qui paye même pas ses impôts en france
en plus de ces une forme
d'externalisation si vous voulez de la
puissance publique au profit d'intérêts
privés parce qu'en plus ces cabinets ils
ont d'autres clients donc il ya des
questions déontologiques extrêmement
lourde en fait qu'ils sont qui sont
posées dans cette question je voyais que
même la commission européenne est aussi
dans ce type de stratégie et appel après
on nous parle de souveraineté européenne
non on a en fait en france des
fonctionnaires compétentes et compétents
on doit élever le niveau d expertise de
l'état et donc en fait c'est l'héritage
si vous voulez de 30 ans discours sur
abba les fonctionnaires l'état coûte
trop cher etc etc qui amène à ce type de
dérive extrêmement grave
[Musique]